Quarry Road in Corey said hey David are
there already things that were socially
acceptable when you were younger but now
they aren't even though you're only in
your early thirties yes they're
absolutely have been changes during my
life number one smoking in bars and
restaurants at least in the United
States it used to be totally normal that
there's a smoking section inside of
restaurants and I know that they're
still parts of the country where that I
guess is allowed although I don't
remember having been to any of those
places in my life uh not in the last ten
years anyway uh but in the Northeast on
the west coast in most places that I go
to the idea of going into a part of the
restaurant and smoking I mean I'm
guessing that to you pat that sounds
crazy right I mean there's this one
restaurant where I did remember they had
smoking section in a non-smoking section
yeah but even in in my early childhood
when I go back to those times I never
saw anyone smoking in those areas so it
was already sort of on its way out
smoking on planes is another one I
remember out going to Argentina to visit
my family in 1992 it was my first trip
back after coming to the United States
and there was a smoking section still on
international flights I think that maybe
domestic flights had banned smoking at
that point obviously it's ridiculous in
principle to think that it it makes any
sense whatsoever to be smoking on a
plane but the concept of a smoking
section of on a plane is also insane
it's completely enclosed right I get
yeah you keep the smokers at the back
and you keep first class at the beach at
the front or whatever up but the smoke
drifts throughout the cabin yeah that's
totally baffling to think about now how
we would have smoking sections on a
plane I mean everyone's sharing the same
air in that yet that very small amount
of area never made sense to me at all
and then the other one that I think is
somewhat changed is showing up
unannounced in different social
scenarios it was already starting to
sort of go out of style when I was
younger but now with texting and social
media and all the stuff the the idea of
just showing up unannounced at people's
houses is not done too frequently maybe
with like close-knit neighbors or maybe
family you still see it but I wouldn't
really think of just showing up
unannounced at a friend's house in in
2016 yeah that makes sense because back
in the day you would have to RSVP via
landline phone
I email even and we're telegram now
there's he i telegraphed force code that
now there's so many different ways to do
it here's the last one I want to mention
memorizing phone numbers okay now if you
have a lot of your friend's phone
numbers memorized it almost seems like
something might be wrong with you
because why would you ever need to
memorize someone's phone but I i still
remember from when i would just have
people's phone numbers memorized uh you
like for example former producer lewis's
home number the number that is still his
parents number i have that number
memorized because when i was a kid i
would call it all the time a lot of my
friends who were the first ones to get
mobile phones I I still have all the
numbers memorized but people like more
recently met if i were to tell them hey
yeah you know it just just as a goof uh
uh just to mention this offhandedly I I
know your phone number by heart I think
it would almost be seen as creepy yeah
they would think that is kind of weird I
mean we have a call in number for the
show and I hear you say it may be 10
times a week you still don't have it
memorized yeah that's right uh that's a
very good point so I think that that's
something that is significantly changed
even since i don't know like 12 years
ago when i first had a cell phone those
are some thoughts any other your others
things that have changed in terms of
social conventions uh that used to be
socially acceptable and now are not i
think vice versa there's a lot more
things that are now socially acceptable
that didn't used to be a lot of this
probably relates to like online dating
apps and a lot of these types of things
but not the question that was asked i
will stick to only Cory's question which
we have now answered